back in 2013 a streamer named zillion op
convinced his fans that he was disabled
and bound to a wheelchair
and then allegedly he managed to rake in
20 000
in donations to help with that
disability except
he wasn't disabled like at all he
eventually got caught and twitch
permabanned him
immediately and gave refunds to the
people who subbed to his channel
but now years later he's back streaming
on twitch under a different
name so let's break down what happened
with this [ __ ]
alright guys so the score esports is
streaming over at twitch.tv
the score esports make sure you follow
the channel so you know exactly when we
go live with shows like clouded
stomp our squad or whatever crazy
nonsense we come up with
so back in late 2012 still the early
days of twitch
zillion op streamed world warcraft and
diablo while also goofing around with
his girlfriend
hey guys zilliano p here and his fans
noticed that he always streamed from a
wheelchair
when they asked about it zillion said
that he didn't have the use of his legs
but he would never get into the
specifics of his disability so as word
of mouth spread about this disabled
streamer his channel started to grow
as people came to donate money to help
with alleged medical costs
now remember this is late 2012 still the
early days of twitch where
pulling in 200 viewers which zillion did
was actually
pretty good and he even managed to get
partnered and according to multiple
sources that were around during the time
of the incident
zillion managed to pull in twenty
thousand dollars from his audience
after saying that he needed to raise
money for things like a new wheelchair
and physiotherapy but here's the problem
it was all [ __ ]
zillion wasn't disabled he had full use
of his legs and he never needed a
wheelchair
speculation that this was all a scam
started after zillion's facebook page
was hacked
with the hacker calling him out for not
being disabled
then we got even more proof that zillion
wasn't disabled when
he got up from his wheelchair and walked
away
during a stream expansion when it's
easily out geared
oh my god we took our dog the story goes
that zillion needed to go afk
for a second and then allegedly forgot
to switch the stream overlay to cover
the camera
and in the clip you can hear his
girlfriend say oh my god
as he gets up this dude couldn't even be
a scumbag
properly the chat was obviously super
confused and zilean and his girlfriend
quickly tried to cover it up and pass it
off as him
falling down now a lot of this footage
and chat's reaction has since been
deleted
but thanks to youtuber wavywebsurf we
have an idea of what went down
what the [ __ ] did zillion just stand lol
zillion
no i fell panthoria roflmal
zillion i pushed off my chair and ate it
zillion
[ __ ] dog zillion he was dumping water
on my wires
zillion i'm pissed and in pain zillion
i need to fix myself panthoria
poor angel zillion and my dog dumped
water on everything
zillion i will try and be back zillion
it hurts to breathe i hit my side on the
corner of the desk
zillion i'm going to die for a few
zillion i will try to be back soon as
you can imagine the backlash was fierce
there are dozens of reaction videos
online of people just yelling at this
dude for being a piece of [ __ ] who faked
a disability
and then twitch got involved stating
that he was permabanned from the
platform
they even went so far as to refund
people who had subbed to his channel
quote the twitch broadcaster zillion
opie did indeed have his channel closed
and his partnership contract terminated
on the basis of fraud moving forward
we'll be offering refunds to those who
subscribe to his channel through twitch
we have a zero tolerance policy for this
type of behavior
and the character demonstrated in this
situation is truly reprehensible
his actions are a huge slap in the face
to twitch community members
with real disabilities such as aeron and
groups such as ablegamers
who have helped spread a message of
inclusiveness and positivity
to not only the twitch community but
gaming as a whole
end quote and oh yeah that facebook
hacker that i mentioned the one that
called out zillion for not actually
having a disability
well they came back and revealed
themselves to be an old youtube friend
of his
now i really only have one question what
the [ __ ] did he think was gonna happen
was this just supposed to continue for
years think about this
let's say zillion continued streaming
till september of 2015 which is when
twitch hosted its first twitchcon
was this idiot just gonna roll up and
pretend that he had a disability
in front of thousands of people now i
have no idea what zillion had been up to
since he was banned
but fast forward a few years to this
week
and he popped back up on twitch for a
little while
anyway
that clip comes from a reddit thread
accusing zillion of streaming under a
different account called it's bluish
also remember the alleged friend and
facebook hacker that i mentioned
that same guy was the one who created
the reddit thread
to be clear while multiple people
throughout the thread point out that
it's definitely a zillion
we haven't been able to verify that in a
few hours after the reddit thread
accusing zillion went
up the it's bluish account was banned
from twitch
so let's just summarize this it appears
that zelenop
faked the disability and got banned from
twitch because of it
then came back years later without the
wheelchair
and promptly got banned again this dude
is like an og example of streamers
getting caught in their own lies
and since then there's been a few other
notable examples
there was that league streamer trick to
g who fake swatted himself to celebrate
800 000 twitch followers
or hell what about mk tom brady a
streamer who got fans to donate money so
he could attend a mortal kombat
tournament
he never showed up and then lied about
being there and once he admitted that he
was never actually at the tournament you
know that the community went wild with
those memes
but to lighten the mood members of the
fgc started photoshopping him into
pictures of nec
and then eventually other pictures too
because if this dude is going to suck
ass to an entire community
the least the community can do is clown
on him right back look it's 2020 we know
that some crazy [ __ ] can happen with
live streaming
but this zillion guy definitely crossed
the line
when you stream on twitch there's an
unspoken trust between the streamer and
the fans especially when there's money
involved
and zillion he completely destroyed that
please fix this [ __ ] jank headphone
setup yeah
so i turned you keith up although i
don't have speakers
right i don't have speakers to like hear
you guys through some [ __ ] speakers
hey i'm not i'm not ripping on it i i
understand you know like
i gotta have that dj you know yeah it's
just the [ __ ] you know
[Music]